as I work out now by in my garage I kind
of go to the gym and I just kind of do
my workouts and I noticed Men's Health
asked me if I wanted to do one of their
uh workout videos and Men's Health and I
was like [__] yeah sign me up and then I
was like wait a minute how do I do it
though because
uh the camera crew is we can't do it at
my gym because of the coronavirus I was
like did they just there's a camera crew
come to my house and I work out in my
garage and they were like no you'd shoot
it yourself and send it to them and
they'll cut it together and I go like
this
bye
I'm not going to do it my [__] self
dude
so I've been looking at these videos I
love the videos I think Men's Health put
together some cool [__] and then I went
into other videos that were like less
professional
and why don't any of these Marvel actors
or actors that are getting jacked for
movies the whether it be the rock or
anybody
the videos should just be
here's how [__] The Rock gets jacked
here's how Hugh Jackman got jacked for
Logan
and then a guy comes down he's like hi
this is how Hugh Jackman got jacked for
Logan
steroids
Hugh Jackman just like doing doing
Freeze Frame biceps
[Music]
they use steroids that's why they look
like a painting bro I work out so
[__] hard and your boy eats every now
and then slipped up a little bit tonight
it's a magnet parmesan but it was yummy
and bro I work out hard as [__] dude I
go hard I keep my brow furrowed and I'm
always in kibadachi and that means horse
stance in Japanese dude I'm
Multicultural and so I do that [__] and
I'm sweating
yeah you boys got some [__] ABS but
your boy's not looking like the rock
your boy's not looking like Hugh Jackman
and
in uh Logan your boy's not looking like
[__] Chris Evans in Captain America
or even Chris Pratt in Guardians of the
Galaxy do you know why because they're
cycling
foreign
they're using roids dude why is that not
something why are they even making those
videos well here's what a lot to do Hugh
Jackman's like is what I like to do you
know I go ahead I do dead lifts and then
I run on the treadmill for an hour and
then I'll do deadlifts and then I'll
[__] do more deadlifts and then I do
uh I do like a [__] chest exercises
my trainer he's bald and he's not even
really he's a lot of he's got the
trainers that they got they're always
like fat a little bit he's fat he's bald
and he's fat but there's more trainer
thanks to him thanks to him oh yeah and
there was something else I was
forgetting also thanks to steroids
drink
then
and guess what though dude
and I'm telling you right now
this ain't [__]
I'm doing a [__] movie it's not in
the foreseeable future yet but dude say
I won't be in an action movie first of
all I got one coming out called Army of
the Dead your boy [__]
your boy [__] what where are you
going where are you going that's me
where you going
that's me bro you're saying I don't look
legit where you go put that down put
that down put that down
okay that's your boy and I'm all geared
up from the feet up I got [__] full
clothes on because I play a helicopter
pilot so I'm in an action movie coming
out whether you like it or not okay
when I really get the shits
when I'm really with the shits dude
oh
when your boy's sliding over [__] car
roofs on his ass and the jackets picking
out the back
when your boys got one [__] gun in
one hand and the other hand's
loosey-goosey because he needs to slide
over the [__] hood of the car with
the jacket picking out the back
say I won't
say I won't walk slow motion while
[__] a car explodes in the background
say I won't not look back
say I won't not look back your boy will
do it
and when your boy does it
and when your boy works out real hard
for that role
your boy
is also going to be doing steroids
and that's no joke and I can't wait till
somebody says so how'd you get fit you
know as if Jay Leno's still a thing so
how do you get a fan for the wrong you
know
steroids Jay
welcome man thank you for tonight
[__] lats looking like a turtle red
then and then ran out then zooming in a
[__] the whole movie was shot on my
back rent that then there and pam pam
oh suicide is painless
it's not you know it is maybe if you
[__]
[__] it dude
that's the [__] man when your boys
really with the shits I'm doing steroids
when the [__] goes down
I don't give a [__] gap tooth bald as
[__] jacked like a turtle
and moving slow too because my joints
hurt
yeah dude I will do steroids can't wait
just getting so mad at my girl oh
chicken
where's the chicken I gotta eat the
chicken [__] now I gotta eat it after
I [__] work out I gotta eat it now
she's like what's wrong just seeing
seeing the back of my throat with my
teeth closed because the [__] Gap is
so big you could buy a cable knit
sweater in it
[__] it dude I'm doing it all
I'm a [__] winner
and you are too dude
that's what this podcast is about coming
together this is a cult
coming together in this cult
and when I take steroids I'm being
honest with you babies I haven't yet I
haven't even taken whatever they call it
any kind of thing some guy came up to
the gym are you taking tea or sub
testosterone your boy goes all natural
man
and it's hard but when that movie comes
along
well they want you to all take steroids
don't worry
if you'd like to make a call please
Perrier make bigger [__] cans dude
what is this a [__] penis dude that's
how big my penis is I swear to God
um yeah bro you know
I gotta start doing that anyway dude
that the workout celeb the videos are
hilarious
we do six sets of [__]
chin ups and then six sets of the things
yeah yeah yeah okay cool and then you
[__] shoot up in your [__]
anyway
watch my Netflix special